hey guys this is Pete peppers with candy
crush soda saga tips com and I'm here to
make another commentary video with tips
for you to help you get through level 4
40 and this soda saga this is a pretty
tough one a lot of ice in the middle
here and we have to get down and get all
the Bears all 14 bears out so it's a
real it's a real pain so let's just give
it a look so obviously we want to work
our way down there's a few small pink
fish and underneath the ice but they
don't really do a whole lot so in the
very beginning all I'm really trying to
do is free up this licorice at the
bottom like we did right there on the
right so that way I can get rid of those
because as you can see those dispensers
down there bring up wrapped candies so
I'm gonna calm bday shin or whatever the
board gives me and my Sparkle show or
sprinkle shall I should say to see how I
use the blue here so that I could bring
up the that Reds wrapped on the right
side and I can't do anything with it yet
but I'm going to continue to do the same
thing you know look for look for
specials that I can fire down there or
use the sparkle shell again whenever it
comes up so
board small you know you want to open it
up to you know try to what we do want to
try to like get down in one spot where
we connect the bottom dispensers to the
top but as you know since you probably
played this a few times already it's
frustrating because you can't just go
and do whatever you want so now i use
the shell on the red to blow up that on
the right hand side and i got a nice
cascade when i did that that gave me a
colouring candy so i'm going to try to
combo that with something here's a
striped combo so this is going to help
out tremendously i'll go ahead and use
this there's not really any red on the
board but there is purple i could go
ahead and shoot that off first to try to
drop a couple more i did i think now
I'll just just go ahead and use this I
don't want to waste any moves because
I'm gonna need them all once I get going
here so okay so this is what we've been
essentially trying to do which is get
each one of these wraps at the bottom
has another wrapped under the ice above
so we want to make that combo and now
this is where things get a little bit
interesting because we're starting to
open it up but at the same time we still
have a lot of way to get a lot of long
way to go so we really want to be
careful but what we want to do is we
want to make it down from the right to
the left since we start on the right
hand side and get all those r @ + wrap
combos that we can and i'm also going to
be trying to manage
the sparkle shell so that I can keep
moving across the side like I did right
there now another thing that you want to
keep in mind while you're playing at
this part is to is now that the board's
opened up you have a lot more chances to
find special so you really want to take
your time at this point to look the
whole board over because you know a nice
color bomb or coloring candy combo away
from the ice they'll be really helpful
and using the sparkle shell takes it
taking out that color also will set up a
lot more opportunities like it did there
for me and you might not get the
colouring candy to drop like that but
you you do want to look for you know
different special matches to make
because there's one less color that's
going to be on the board and that's
going to open things up so that's really
the key the key is to get down to the
bottom and get those get those wrapped
candies acrossed it's really kind of
hard the first time I played it took me
a bunch of tries until I finally got it
this one I got a little bit faster but
even knowing what I had to do it still
took you know a couple tries so I got
the right bored so I hope this will help
if you have any extra questions leave a
comment and please like this video and
subscribe to my channel because you know
I go the extra mile to make these
commentary videos with tips knowing the
other channels do that for this game and
I hope that you'll support me and watch
my videos in the future I'll talk to you
soon thanks